my name is Pierre bad
welcome to the which has it's another
horror game I had made in the RPG maker
which is really cool I'm always
pleasantly surprised when I claim this
you haven't checked out in for example
that was a fantastic game and it's free
so I'm gonna leave it on link in
description and you can just play the
game and come back and then I
Angele now and you can be like beer -
you're supposed to do - not jolly good
all right start off as let who got into
words charlie good
she seems confused where the [ __ ] she's
doing all right I see something blinking
over here right away I'm [ __ ] genius
how do I get there
my god I'm a genius I saw that in two
SEC filed something rusty and shot take
it
I got a machete there's something else
there listen either Tsar not used
automatically stand in front of an
object to interact with and use item
from the menu sometimes I will have
effect simply do so having them in your
possession checking items description
for more info all right
and the [ __ ] do I open the map well I
gotta use the hatch in so I guess this
is you know that how do I open the menu
there we go
machete on that [ __ ] can't even dent in
them really Wow that's [ __ ] bad-ass
roses well that means we're [ __ ]
maybe we can go north
take these wonderful wonderful we don't
even get to say it but hey that's okay
that's a guy all the way the machete
broke
apparently the machete was made out of
glass son of a [ __ ]
oh wow oh I don't know about you bros I
think one of the character type of
horror characters that scare me the most
is probably witches or just old women in
general they scare are you serious
I got to reset everything now what an F
[ __ ] alright I do not expect that son of
a [ __ ] the witch house is a [ __ ] house
I don't know out of all things that
actually appear in [ __ ] horror games
all the way there you can go [ __ ]
themselves I mean babies people are
usually scared of like young babies and
[ __ ] and I'm like just kicked up this
[ __ ] cat gun that's all you got to do
well women they smell and they go near
you and they're like I don't like that
doesn't float my boat you know
alright this time let's not [ __ ] out
what are we having here did I literally
just walk in that room and I saw what
happened alright the items way carry us
that's nice
I like her outfit by the way yes it's
way courier uselessly karakuri curious
so we literally died as soon as we walk
in it like okay oh my god [ __ ] okay
stupid not a kitty cat how did I not see
you there hey what's up kitty cat what
is this it's the [ __ ] cat says right
there actually hmm
so the way I would block up by roses
oh the cat is talking to me you want to
go in my as well if you can't leave
oh I save on the kitty cats cool I'm
actually enjoying this it's a lot better
than just [ __ ] walking in the night
try it's not walk on the blood puddle
what was that there was something there
come to my room all right I like this so
far but I don't know how to go to your
room bro
I like this my god kitty cat I'm Carolee
yo-yo decided that follows you for life
incidentally where the heck do you come
from thanks for saving kitty cat a vase
of roses they're always so creative with
saving all right what do you got
there's a pair of scissor on the right
band [ __ ] take it
over here a dusty old dressing there's
nothing inside Chadwick perhaps I
thought I took get them are there change
to the bench well that's not good
let's check this this room out huh this
is actually kind of spooky
what's up large clock time marches on
well that's always helpful which diary I
was sick so though I played with me my
father and my mother didn't love me well
boo-fucking-hoo I tend to be a rest
against the pile of press yeah we got a
teddy bear a big stuff time what the
hell was that
cookies don't [ __ ] with me cookies open
when the house returns to normal what
the hell does that mean all right I just
got to investigate everything I'm sorry
I just wanna alright so now we have the
teddy that means we can use it on the
chains hmm sup kitty cat that's right yo
cut of beers limbs why would you do that
for teddy
ah and now I have a teddy bear torso it
has blood on it
there are blood is yeah still are a
limbless teddy bear it's red where it's
limbs were no point any I'm saving here
we go son trust Teddy what the hell what
happened get it Teddy don't be mad all
right can you dump her mad I did because
I don't know why I did running be red
limbs everywhere
uh well [ __ ] I don't see what we're
gonna do it
what's that watch okay that's gonna keep
what wait is there another door here
perhaps there's another door here so a
basket has a big teddy bear in it
there's a little bit of room light no
all right I guess I heard a locking
sound somewhere that's a weirdest
locking mckesson and make that one too
[ __ ] I Teddy's you stay strong stay
strong nylon yeah dude shut [ __ ] [ __ ]
teddy to scare the kitty Adam shut up
[ __ ] Texas man well we got to go
through that [ __ ] again I'm putting you
in the back all right all right Eddie
don't kill me I sits on me I guess he
doesn't like it oh I'm supposed to go
nor I'm supposed to go to work I know
now I'm slipping I'm sorry my apologies
press I am NOT a genius
I know or have I ever claimed to be one
all right I take those [ __ ] random
Pol Pot's
scared the [ __ ] out of me but it
shouldn't really do anything I'm open
here you won't have been [ __ ] Spurlin
I don't like this brush what am I
supposed to do
[ __ ] that [ __ ] what am I supposed to be
freaky [ __ ] all right what I was
supposed to do it's just [ __ ] run for
it I can't him
I just [ __ ] barely make it but I
didn't think I could but ah [ __ ] you
Teddy and now he's supposed to go with
some [ __ ] like that I do think so I do
think so
well we know that wouldn't open but we
will go here all right this should be
enough teddy bears lamps
I should say by that Kitty actually my
am while I'm at it yo bear what's up you
want to shave girl that's fat
oh yeah alright let's go in here what is
this this does not look normal
explain this [ __ ] what a stranger
collards soup and a skull shaped ball
drink it nevermind it's probably not
good look inside nothing but soot
ketchup mine mine now
it's like knocking that nice cutting
don't kill me knife someone's invisible
is it what's up
ah I'm busy lend a hand
ah thank you Mesa blue grabs my arm push
your wrist into the cotton ball now a
hand is exactly what I needed
don't do it boy that escalated quickly
that's kind of gross sup kitty I kinda
knew that was gonna happen good hey it's
dying is fun isn't it
we never read this note actually the
cook is busy lend a hand not literally
dining of aristocrats people are ruling
and wealthy classes have long adjoined
dining the silverware by using such hard
to clean cutlery they could hire
servants to demonstrate their health in
addition silver utensils change color
upon contact with the poison making them
quite useful so we need to use the skull
thing I think I got it I'm a [ __ ]
genius yeah let's give him the teddy
hand oh thank you I was in need of a
hand or two let me show you my pretty
change well we got a silver key does it
go here perhaps yeah scoffs eh all right
does it go here perhaps
well they really are no other locked
doors
hit Bowl with key what and makes a place
pleasing sound put the key in the soup
why I made a key sub my favorite the key
turned black in this I heard an
unlocking sound song but what was that
okay
oh [ __ ] you
ketchup bottle is he not here anymore
and the book is closed I don't like this
bras it's [ __ ] give me goose bumps
man what is saved
see mmm save kitty cat got all right
what the [ __ ] is going hey kid can Carla
a dick already forget him gotcha
alright Prez uh I think it will end its
ups today really a lot better than I
found this
I quit if you wanna see more it's this
guy on the resume and I'll see you next
episode
yeah I love my field concept
job out front snap
don't see how this can go bad